foreign
[Applause]
thank you
God Brenda Moore is lucky to try to
review that Skies don't challenge it he
does not like contact and they're on the
net
he feels like there was a poke in there
on the goaltender Anderson yeah right
there
the initial play before kachuk lets the
puck go now is he aided in by hetchy
[Applause]
you can see Anderson trying to wave it
off at the same time but I don't know
that there's a whole lot there and so
look the initials like as he's circling
the stick goes between the legs of
Anderson
[Applause]
we have a situation room
challenge to determine if there's goal
Turner interference prior to the goal
yeah the last minute official review
[Applause]
let's talk about our rules adoles Don
koharski
Coho how did you see it
yeah the focus here is on the Florida
player with that little poke check into
the goaltender I I honestly don't think
it's enough
egregious enough to stay here to to turn
this over so I have good goal here and
even though it's it's right there that's
just sort of a hockey playing
um I don't see anything he does
position
yeah he places it in there he doesn't
hook him doesn't spin them there we go
we got a call
one review but Toronto the situation we
have a good goal
[Applause]
[Music]
and the patience here at Matthew can not
shoot the puck initially that extra
little stick handle bought him the angle
to fire the puck into the back of the
net in a reaction on the bench
and there's his dad
and a reaction
thank you
[Applause]
don't think most guys would have got
that Puck and just
probably swept it at the blue paint but
he knew
where he was and he fought himself a
little bit extra time and an extra what
we could say three feet five feet
gave him the opportunity to put the puck
into the back of the net
superstars make the big plays at the big
times and Matthew Chuck has done that
throughout this series against Carolina
what a series for him Carolina will try
one play here off the neutral zone
Face-Off
s
[Applause]
[Music]
victory
[Applause]